Naomi Watts admits she's just now
watching Game of Thrones I I'm late
coming to it I have to say but that's
how I am with lots of things in life
eg caught up with the actress who has
been cast in the much-anticipated
prequel to the hit HBO show ahead of her
hosting gig at the worldwide orphans
14th annual gala in New York how excited
are you like are you a fan Yana so what
happens now something extraordinary
I am pinching it right now and studying
it's very exciting
it's very exciting she also dished on
what the worldwide orphans changed it's
just really important to see that all
children who are suffering are well
supported - how many years has been
going and impressive well another mother
yourself of course it does you you the
minute you have children nothing
prepares you for that those fears of
their you know health and safety and
then of course as they grow older their
emotional well-being or even when
they're little and this is what Jane's
work is all about is that you know if
they're emotionally supported they're
going to heal faster